so we have blank plus 261 is equal to
630 and i encourage you to pause the
video and see if you can figure out what
blank is
so there's a couple of ways to tackle
this let's visualize it on a number line
so that's my number line right over
there
and we could start at blank or i'll call
that question mark so we could start at
question mark and if we add 261 to it so
if we add 261
plus 261 we can get to 630
we can get
to
630 that's the 630 right over there
which means that if we started at 630
if we start at 630 and we were to
subtract 261 if we were to go the other
way if we were to subtract
261. so let's do that
so minus 261
minus 261. we're going to get back to
blank we're going to get back
to
our question mark now there's a bunch of
ways that you can compute this but i'm
going to try to tackle it in a way that
i would actually try to do it in my head
or it'll simplify my computation it's
just one of many ways to figure this out
so the way i would do it is i would
first subtract 200
so i'd first subtract 200 so that's
about
it's not i'm not drawing it perfectly to
scale so i would subtract 200 so that's
minus 200 right over there which would
get me to 430 i can do that in my head i
just subtracted two hundreds from that
and let's see now i want to subtract 60
so then i would subtract 60
so minus 60.
so let's see 430 minus 60. that's that's
43 tens minus 6 tens well that's going
to be
37 tens or 370. this gets us to 370 and
then we got to subtract one more we have
to subtract 260
and then
we subtract one so 370 minus one
is
369. so this right over here is 360
369. now another way we could have done
it is we could have swapped the order we
could have said if blank plus 261 is 630
we could have said
we could have said 261
plus
plus blank
is equal to 630.
all i did is i swapped the order here
but we can visualize that as a different
as a different thing on the number line
so i'm going to let me draw my number
line again
so
there's my number line
and i could start at 261.
so this time i'm starting at 261 261
and i want to get to 630
and i'm going to get to 630
and the amount that i add is going to be
the blank so let's see what i have to
add to get to 630 and i'm going to add
numbers that are easy for me to compute
so i could add 9
i could add 9. now why did i add 9
because that gets me to 270 which is a
nice round number
and then i could add let's see i could
add 30 here to get to 300 so let me do
that so plus 30 and i'm not doing this
quite to scale but this is going to get
me to 300
and then from 300 to 630 well i i could
just add 330.
so i could just add
i could just add 330 there so how much
did i add in total this is 39 plus 330
that's 369. i added 369.
so these are all ways of getting to the
same value all ways of viewing the same
problem